It's tumeric essential oil with the MSO rubbed right on my
papyrus area, okay, to do three times a day.
So, tumeric essential oil, so I don't think so.
So as I think about it, okay, so what are the benefits of tumeric?
tumeric is a flavonoid, and the benefit is that it has cancer-killing
properties, so tumeric is curcumin, remember, has cancer-killing
properties in itself.
It's anti-inflammatory has all these benefits, but the essential oil
of curcumin, tumeric, I don't know, that's going to be more of an
alkaloid.
I don't know if that has the same properties of the whole plant
flavonoid, so I don't know that that is, it probably wouldn't hurt
anything if you did it three times a day, and the DMSO itself
can be anti-inflammatory, so I don't think that's a wrong
approach, but I don't think you can count that as the benefits of
curcumin, because I don't know much curcumin is actually
in the tumeric essential oil. Most essential oils are
alkaloids, and they have benefits, but I don't think the exact same benefit
of the whole plant, so I don't think there's anything wrong with that,
to answer your question, but I don't know that you're getting the same
benefit of taking tumeric.